have you ever realized that Hollywood
makes it look cool to be dumb think
about it beis and Butthead they were so
dumb and yet
celebrated think about Screech and Steve
Urkel they were the smart guys but they
were bullied and shoved in the locker
while Eddie was Dumb and got all the
girls baby
baby baby baby baby and Zach Morris he
was Dumb and got all the
girls all the television companies out
there are owned by a handful of
individuals seven Giant companies
control More than 70% of the channels on
TV Disney Time Warner News Corp the
Comcast NBC Universal conglomerate
Viacom CBS and Discovery is that a
coincidence or is there a Sinister plot
to dumb down the American citizens to
make them become docile and easier to
control it's time to wake up from the
brainwashing we are concerned
about it's not only cool to be smart but
it's vital let's fight against the
system of satanic control
[Music]